all right let's look at the next
category next category is guest of the
year
now we've had a lot of guests on trash
this year all of them
are right chris is about to follow up
with this chris is one forward tower
it's really the whole episode
that's it since when
now leave it leave it that's good
now obviously we don't you know it's
obviously not uh uh you know the nicest
thing to rank
your guests in order yeah but our hearts
and everyone's hearts
everyone's a number one yeah we just
wanted to see which ones uh you guys
like the most
actually i think we're just curious and
yeah you know we're very grateful for
all the guests that we've had on yeah
absolutely
um you know i i guess this is less to
like
rank everyone and more of just like
awarding you know awarding someone who
really left an impression on the viewers
and that's right and that's how i see it
yeah absolutely so uh
we haven't had a bad guess absolutely
not everyone's been
accepted yes i mean but well let's look
at the nominees i guess just to refresh
our minds on who we've had this year
yeah
jesus christ she's gonna [ __ ] hate me
chris is going to kill you ashley
ashley you're gonna you're really gonna
do a boy like this
so for context this is from the webtoon
that someone is making of us
and they decided to make chris into this
like ball of lard for some reason
that's the only way to describe it
really
and uh yeah ashley was like that's
that's a perfect picture of chris
chris came on episode five episode 30.
yeah yeah so he's the only one who's had
two
yeah and then we have the lovely shibuya
kaho yeah and then we have melee
obviously remember being a guest on here
melin
mainland tries to forget it every day
and then we have the queen of degeneracy
herself
sit snap come on and then we have of
course morocco
who couldn't forget alexi uh we had ken
a wonderfully talented kenator
wonderfully talented nano as well
and we had aki come on lady beard and
last but not least frana scully we've
had a lot of guests on i did not
expect ourselves so many guests once i
started this ten guests well yeah i
think because you know because the
borders haven't been opened we haven't
really been able to get a lot of
international gaston's been
what was the surprise we got as many as
we did yeah honestly because i thought
with you know the world situation being
the way it was that we would be
really really limited with the guests
that we could find yeah because
what is that one every one out of five
episodes was i guessed it so
that means and you know people always uh
you know those complaining being like oh
you should just wave the rule for xxx
situations yeah
no it's like i don't know i think to us
it's like the the
the importance of trash taste is getting
to be with their in person
and the chemistry and also getting to
meet with them before yeah getting hang
out with them afterwards you know making
sure that it's not just
uh come on my show [ __ ] off you know
come hang out with us because it's like
every single guest we've had we've
really had like a proper like connection
yeah after their episode has aired and
like i hope that conveys to
the audience as well because one of the
biggest things that before we decided to
have guests on is that we didn't want to
just
interview our guests we wanted the
guests to be you know part of part of
the roundtable
there's nothing there's nothing better
than an in-person interaction yeah in my
opinion
part of my favorite part of having a
guest on isn't just the recording the
episode it's just hanging out afterwards
we just enjoy we just enjoy hanging out
and meeting people chris getting us
violently drunk yeah
the normal stuff that happens when you
have chris on of course but everyone has
been fantastic but of course they can
only be one winner
let's find out who the viewers voted for
yeah how's that i'm
i'm curious if it'll be a correlation of
views on the episode
[Music]
is
the percentage it was pretty [ __ ]
ridiculous wasn't it he won with 37.2
percent
that's quite a lot that's pretty high
there's ten nominees i can't believe
chris [ __ ] won
that means chris has won best kissed and
laziest trip
and biggest uh no ira's biggest clown i
wish it was chris he was he was the
greatest guest but goddamn was his
other game maybe chris will be in and
running for biggest clown next
year next episode chris is going to
[ __ ] rock up
suit blazer yeah
just whenever chris is next on yeah yeah
but he inevitably comes on
i'm sure he will when he comes when he
inevitably comes on again we don't have
a choice he just turns up
a tuesday he just turned yeah what's
going on
i think that was the last recording
where he just texted us one day and he's
like lads recording recording yeah
recording yes
i guess so all right cool i loved how he
was like i didn't know people were gonna
watch this podcast when i first came on
so i didn't care i think that's why he
won lazy's trip
because he turns up in a shirt the
second time
give a [ __ ] he was like no one's gonna
watch trash tape
this is good this is this trash this
podcast is gonna go down after three
episodes it's fine no no he's like
please let me back off
now chris look at us now yeah well i
understand why you know
i think his chris fits in so well yeah
it's it's understandable it's nothing
but background
yeah yeah yeah i thought that we're
giving him [ __ ] now you know just uh
guess shows i'm sure i'm sure he'll give
a [ __ ] but again please go and watch
every single guest episode that we've
had on
every single guest has been [ __ ]
amazing so shout out to you guys for
helping us make the show better yeah
thank you i mean i
thank you to everyone who came on we had
a [ __ ] fantastic time in
every episode that we filmed so far and
anyone we'd love to have you on again
hopefully uh we can add to this wall
this year as well in the new wall yeah i
hope this doesn't give the impression
that we can only even reinvite chris
yeah
anyone is there anyone is
exactly